[Music]
critics say cancel culture has struck
again
from those two top editors resigning
from the New York Times in the
Philadelphia Inquirer after these
stories ran in their papers - now when
the classic film from 1939 Gone with the
Wind now gone temporarily from HBO as
they add historical context to it and
the hit TV shows cops and live PD also
getting cancelled what does this hole
mean and how did we wind up here let's
talk to the author of don't burn this
book Dave Rubin Dave good morning to you
you've been talking about canceled
culture for about five years and here we
are here we are well first off I just
want to let you know that I did actually
cancel my HBO account yesterday I'm
pretty sure I have some family members
that aren't that happy with me if you
know what I mean yes you know you may
remember a season 7 episode of Seinfeld
where Kramer goes to March in the AIDS
March and he refuses to wear the ribbons
so he's doing the good thing but he just
doesn't want to wear a ribbon and what
happens is the mob decides to beat the
crap out of Kramer and that basically is
where we're at at this point what what
the left has become is a amorphous mob
that will take out anyone who does not
bow immediately when they want you to
bow I mean the idea we're gonna take
gone with the wind ah gone with the wind
off HBO we could take everything off
there is literally every television show
ever I mean look at Family Guy The
Simpsons Seinfeld every comedy will be
gone Curb Your Enthusiasm will be gone
are we gonna take off police academy
movies I mean we could go through the
litany of things that might trigger
somebody that might offend somebody this
is art I mean we're gonna have to go
through all our all our music all our
movies all our TV shows and what we'll
be left with is you're gonna have to sit
in a room with nothing in it and and
keep quiet this is this thing is out of
control where are the adults in the room
where is
someone that is in corporate America
that says no you know what Gone with the
Wind stands on its own as a movie of its
time and and we're gonna leave it there
we don't need to put a warning before
someone watches a movie we're not
children and yet we're being treated
like children you know you know what HBO
is gonna do is they're gonna add some
kind of historical perspective about
where we were as a nation back in 1939
when it came out and when one of the
stars won the Oscar as well in a
landmark award win Ted Cruz tweeted this
out
I wanted you your reaction here's a
radical idea don't censor gone with the
wind don't censor Blazing Saddles don't
censor Quentin Tarantino don't censor
anything you know you were talking about
the political level you're a registered
Democrat you're living in California you
were part of the political left for a
little while why did you make this this
trip to where you are right now you're
going for me early in the morning I am a
registered Democrat here in California
but I want to be very clear that that
really is just for technical purposes
because you know California and LA
specifically it's such a democratic
stronghold that I want to be able to
vote in primaries to try to make things
a little more centrist so I actually
voted for Biden in the primary which was
really only a vote against Bernie but
yes I was a progressive for most of my
life and we're seeing the fruits of what
the progressives bring you every city
right now that is that is rioting or
Seattle with its autonomous zone which
sounds like some sort of dystopian
sci-fi movie like district 9 these are
all run by far left progressives why is
it that la my mayor is bending his knee
to protesters and rioters and it's
happening in Seattle and it's happening
in New York City with de Blasio oddly
it's not happening in conservative or
right leaning or Republican cities
because there is a belief in rule of law
but one of the things that I've been
talking about for years is what the left
does is that they because they feel
something strongly no one will ever
stop somebody else from doing something
so if you feel something strongly that
means it's right and the guy next to you
feel something strongly so that means it
right so they're always in a constant
road to chaos and and we're seeing that
right now and even this morning you know
President Trump tweeted something about
what's happening in Seattle and instead
of responding in a mature way the the
mayor basically mocked him and said
something about go back to your bunker
but it's her City that now has a
six-block radius of absolute anarchy so
if this is what you want if you if
you're watching you know what's
happening in these progressive cities if
this is what you want then keep voting
for these people but if this isn't what
you want and by the way I don't think
90% of America actually wants chaos on
the streets then we're gonna have to
start voting these people out pretty
quick all right he knows something about
product placement because his book is
right over his shoulder
Dave Reubens don't burn the not bad
right do you think for yourself in an
age of unreason very good product
placement David thank you very much for
joining us live from out on the left
coast if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell